أوكرانيا كما قال الرئيس لم
تدخل جدارًا من القوة في
الشعب الأوكراني فحسب ، بل إنها تستعد
لضرب جدار من الخرسانة في هذه المدن.
بالنسبة لأفضل جيش إذا
تمكنت من سحبهم إلى التضاريس الحضرية ، فهذا
كابوس حي بالنسبة
لهم ونعرف ما سيحدث ،
وأعتقد أنه من المفارقات استنادًا إلى
الدراسات التاريخية التي نعتقد
أن الروس لديهم قوة هائلة
مقارنة بالقوة الأوكرانية
في  تحتاج المعارك الحضرية إلى خمسة
أضعاف عدد القوات ضد مدافع واحد ،
لذا إذا كنت تحسب عدد المقاتلين
حتى لو لم تحسب المدنيين
داخل كييف ، فإن ما يجلبه بوتين
لا يكفي
حتى لو كنت تحسب القوة الكاملة
التي وضع فيها  أوكرانيا أنت تعرف 190.000
جندي من التحالف الأمريكي في
غزو العراق الذي كنت جزءًا منه قفزت
إلى شمال العراق وكانت جزءًا من
الغزو واستولت عليه.  wn بغداد كان فقط
حوالي 177000 وأخبرك أن العراق ليس
أوكرانيا ، لقد تم الدفاع بشكل طفيف
بالكاد على الإطلاق وكان الجحيم لا يزال
هناك احتمال ، وأنا
أتفق بالفعل مع تخمينك السابق أن هذا
سيكون سيئًا حقًا بالنسبة للروسيين
العسكريون الذين ليسوا الأفضل الذي
أظهروه بالفعل بينما كنت تتحدث عن
مدى عدم
استعدادهم
لنفاد المعدات
وأن نكون صادقين وقد ذكرت قبل
بضع دقائق فقط أن هذا يتعلق بإرادة جميع
المحاربين حول إرادة كلا الجانبين  إنها
قدرتك على إيقاع إرادتك على الجانب
الآخر ، فالأوكرانيون لديهم الإرادة
لدفع الثمن النهائي للروس الذين
تعرفهم وأنا أعلم أن
الجنود الروس ليس لديهم الإرادة لدفع
الثمن النهائي
الذي أحبطوا معنوياتهم بالفعل.  لا أعرف الخطة
الجارية ليس لديهم الوقت
لمحاصرة هذه المدينة. أعتقد أنه من
غير المرجح أن يحاصروا كييف